j'ai un problème on nous achète très
cher des vaccins alors qu'il existe
d'autres vaccins beaucoup moins cher et
peut-être avec moins de risques
là je pense qu'il faudrait une enquête
internationale plus neutre plus
objective et pas avec tout ses intérêts
commerciaux
je trouve que déjà les vaccins devraient
être gratuits il n'y a pas de raisons
soient réservés aux riches à ceux qui
peuvent le payer et ensuite il faudrait
vraiment contrôler ce qui se passe or
dans mon livre je retrace les liens de
pfizer
les liens de corruption nos biens après
le mot avec l'establishment politique et
militaire aux états unis et donc ce sont
des déchirements qui je n'ai pas une
grande confiance
il ya un grand problème on leur paye
très cher pour des vaccins et ils nous
disent oui mais s'il ya des effets
négatifs et des conséquences et que vous
en mourrez ça c'est pas nous qui payons
c'est vous en les profits vont chez eux
et les dommages et les pertes
éventuelles et les risques sont pour
nous alors que leur recherche repose
principalement sur j'étudiais aussi dans
le bouquin repose principalement sur des
recherches publics des universités et à
fonds publics
c'est quelque chose c'est un cliché sa
du nil du néolibéralisme en multi le
prix vi est très performant le public
savoure rien et le privé a refusé depuis
20 ans travaillé sur les coronavirus et
sur toutes les grandes épidémies du sud
qui pose problème parce que ces gens là
sont pas rentables donc non le privé
n'est pas efficace et il se base en
général et notamment pour les
médicaments mais aussi pour
l'informatique et des technologies sur
des recherches publiques qui ont été
financés par l'état donc si vraiment
nous avons déjà payé pour ces vaccins
autant qu'ils aient un contrôle public
et qu'on puisse être beaucoup plus
neutre sur le plan économique par
rapport à ce qui doit être guidé
uniquement par la santé
[Musique]